if you were to design a version control
system specifically for code what would
it look like in the rest of this lesson
we'll be discussing many ways version
control systems can be different and
what a programmer would want in each
case Wikipedia and Google Docs are
clearly not designed for writing code
they require you to use their
special-purpose editors that don't have
any features that programmers tend to
want an editor like syntax highlighting
and parentheses matching using Dropbox
is a more plausible alternative here
since you can use any editor you want
and the files are saved on your computer
as well as in the cloud similarly when
you save copies manually you can edit
with whatever program you prefer
Wikipedia also doesn't actually save
files on your computer which would make
it hard to run your code Google Drive
does let you save your Google Docs files
on your own computer but they're in a
special format that only works with
their special purpose editor and you
can't access the history offline Dropbox
is similar again you can edit your files
on your own computer but you can only
see the history online manual saving is
the only option here that you can use
offline of course syntax highlighting an
offline access to history aren't the
only areas where programmers would want
different features in that version
control the next feature I want to
consider is whether users should
manually choose when to save or whether
the system should save versions
automatically let's think about which
option will be better for code as a
programmer when would you want to have
versions of your code saved consider a
few different use case scenarios when
you're coming up with your answer one
option would be at regular intervals
maybe every hour or maybe whenever
there's a big enough change maybe 50
lines or so or maybe when there's a long
pause in editing or lastly when you
choose to save a version